all right well bill yes
well bill uh where'd you grow up where
are you from i grew up i grew up i i i
was born in minneapolis and i grew up in
saint paul minnesota
and tell me about your childhood yeah
both your my childhood oh okay um
i'm gonna chill um i've been on the
streets all my life i was born you know
i was born in a sh
in an alley in chicago on addison street
i was born there because my
my dad my real dad who couldn't couldn't
drive me my mother to the hospital
because he was too drunk
so she just gave birth to me in an alley
in chicago
that's what happened there and and then
and then okay and then uh
my my my real dad left me when i was
seven years old
okay and my mother remarried when i was
nine okay to a guy named dennis lee
and he's a real piece of [ __ ] and this
guy but anyways he densely always
brought
drugs into my mom's house always brought
drugs brought acid
lsd [ __ ] crystal meth [ __ ] huh
what else
cocaine uh heroin always brought hard
drugs in my mom's house and
i i i caught one of that and i always
stole his drugs
to give to my older friends and to and i
started getting high on it
and so and i've been getting it i've
been getting high all my life
and and uh what did you start using
drugs i started using
drugs at the age of seven and that was
lsd i started using lsd at the age of
seven i have i did and
then and then it just just went up from
there and then
i've been in prison i started going to
prison when i was 18. the feds
put me in prison at the age of 18 for
four ounces of cocaine
and a shotgun i did six years on that
and the feds they took away my american
rights for that
and then i got out i'm paroled and i
violated my pro came back
i went back i went back came back out my
credit was gone
all my credit my credit is gone i got no
credit cause the defense the feds stole
my credit i got nothing
they left me nothing a high and drive
like a bumper
it's it's best i'm so pissed i don't
know what to do i can't get no work in
there like
at all i can't get no work at all you're
in that like are you trying to get jobs
yes i'm i'm a skilled tradesman i'm a
journeyman
in three trades a carpenter roof or
heavy equipment operator i'm pretty bad
ass
and i can't get to work the only work
that's doing in construction is latino
people and they won't hire me for some
reason i don't know what's up man
i don't know i'm getting ready to start
doing these banks i'm still getting
ready to start doing these banks really
have
to get ready to start doing these
pictures i
just might have to i need money man i
need lots of money i need a harley
davidson because i do bike runs
i'm i'm a minnesota hellsinger i'm
minnesota elizabeth that's where i am
and i'm looking to look for the
president of my club because he turned
on
everybody to the feds fbi atf dna what
is your drug today
huh what drugs are using today i'm
crystal i use crystal meth
that's that's that's crystal meth is
what i use that's my favorite drug
that's what i use when's the last time
you slept about a week ago
i stayed for a long while i'd say it was
long miles i could go i go a couple
weeks at a time without sleeping
i go i go i go long time without food or
water
i've got i've gone 60 days without water
before 60 days without water before most
people be dead after not having water in
six days but i've gone six days ago
i've got i've gone three months without
food three months without food
i have i really have how do you how do
you pay for things like drugs or
whatever
food or anything i live on ssi i live on
society that's what i live on
i get 9.85 a month that's what i get and
uh
and the only kind of stealing i do i
steal from stores i boost from stores
that's why i do a shoplift so i do and i
got a fence that buys
all the burnt [ __ ] merchandise i bring
to them yeah eventually somebody
buys a fence is someone who's buying
stolen merchandise
a fence is someone who buys stolen she
does and i got a friend
got a fence real close by from here real
close by
i've been in skip roll been a skate roll
a long time i used to live here i was
i was here for about five years i i got
pulled out of it well i thought i didn't
play it's 2021.
i was here for five years straight skid
row i was living right down sixth in
saint julian where do you stay now
i'm staying in venice beach what are you
doing down here
huh what are you doing downtown uh uh
visiting that defense that
my associates that [ __ ] make money
with yeah
huh yeah i got three kids i got a
daughter that's 36 years old
i got a son that's 31 and i got a son
that's 29.
did you raise them no i was in i was in
the penitentiary for their lives
and i'm very pissed off at myself about
that and i want to have more babies
i want to yeah i want to get a
girlfriend him on babies because i want
more babies
i want i want to do it right if i have
more babies i'm going to do right
i'm not going to leave him ever i'm not
going to leave at all i'm not leaving my
people
my kids ever again because i i left my
other i left my
i left my my woman shelly maskey in 95
because she got addicted to my cocaine i
was selling cocaine in minnesota and she
got addicted to my cocaine
and i left we weren't getting along so i
left and it was the worst mistake i left
okay i keep my ass and i kicked my ass i
kicked myself in the ass
every day about it because that was a
big mistake because i left my little
boys i got two little boys that left
i care very much about them i haven't
seen them since also i still have been
home
you've done a lot of prison time huh
after you have done last night what kind
of i just got out of
school huh what got you in uh prison uh
drugs
i started doing drugs for the feds the
feds put me in prison when i was 18.
and back in the eight it was in 1984
back in 1984
you could propose to go to the military
and still go to prison
and i did and they said no you're going
to prison they want me to go to prison
they want to go to military you want to
go to prison
ronald reagan ruled my life ronald
reagan today because he declared war on
drugs on national tv
declared war on drugs two months later
they blew down my door
two months later the feds blew down my
door and the grandmother
the grandmother and my daughter
introduced me to the informant
that gave me the you they they that had
me
sold to the to the feds they introduced
me in the informant
so there's i don't say stitches
everywhere man i can't stand them
i can't stand so man my life is is a
wreck man
it's a wreck what emotions do you go
through i go through
lots of emotions i i've been crying
lately i i just i cried to myself i
don't cry to anybody but i just cried to
myself
and i don't know i just get very mixed
emotions
and i'm very pissed off i'm getting
ready i'm getting ready to start serial
killing
l.a because that la's been real dog
these people around here there's some
real [ __ ] up people around here
i'm gonna really start sure killing all
that i really am i'm getting ready to
steal kills yes i really am and i'm very
good at it was the last time you spoke
with your kids
oh seven i took my youngest son
to get his license he was 16 years old i
was in 07
and uh took him to get his driver's
license he has driver's license
and uh that's like some machinima man
what do you worry about bill
huh what do you worry about what am i
worried about yeah do you worry about
anything
are you afraid of anything no i don't
really don't get afraid too much
i i worry but i don't get afraid too
much what do you worry about
i worry about uh not not not having
money i worry about not having
stuff to eat i'm worried about not
having cigarettes to smoke
i'm worried about not living good i'm
worried about life in general
i i just said i listened my life is very
unpredictable
but it's i guess i chose that way but
the feds
they they put me in prison the age 18
and they wrecked my [ __ ] life my life
has been a living hell ever since
i i can't change it and the feds took
away my credit so i got no credit
i've never had credit in my life and
they stay you know
what what are you proudest of what what
are you proudest of in your life
proudest of winning
powerlifting trophies i used to power
lifts back in the 90s i was powerlifting
at at powerlifting meets and winning
trophies
that's right yeah i train i train very
hard in gyms
when i'm in the gym and i do steroids
and i get real big and real strong
i do and i lift lots of weight man
do you feel like your life has meaning
yeah my life has meaning i i think it
does
but what do you do well what i do i'm
i'm an outlaw motorist i'm a
i'm a biker man and that has a lot of
meaning for me and uh
i need him a harley davidson so i can
ride and so i do so i can do these
[ __ ] runs so i do these runs all
around
around here man i got to do these
motorcycle runs i got to be there man
and see who's there
and see what's up man i got to be there
because i'm a minnesota hell's angel
and i'm being forget about in these
california hills ages and i don't know
what's everyone
yeah i don't see around anywhere in the
city of angels and up here so i'm so
[ __ ] pissed
and i will confront these [ __ ] about
it man i will
i'll [ __ ] do this man they're leaving
me hanging they leave you they got me
hanging man
because that's me i ain't got no right
man i got no wheels do you have any
friends
very few fair share i got maybe two
friends in los angeles
that's it too that's it they have a very
good friend
that takes care of my assets for me
because i live on ssi
he's got my debit card right now he
controls my money for me
so you know that's what he does for me
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
most important lesson i've learned is uh
never never leave your woman or your
kids
never leave them because when you leave
them someone else is right there
right there taking filling in your shoes
for this what's your biggest regret my
biggest regret
my biggest regret is
not graduating from high school that's
my biggest regret
okay if you had your life to do over
what what kind of things would you have
done
going to high school yeah go to high i
would what would i do over
i i would like to get into the military
i want to be a marine soldier i want to
be in the united states marine corps
but they didn't want me to be in united
marine corps they want me to go to
prison
i don't understand it at all man i don't
know do you feel like the childhood that
you had
were there drugs in your house when you
were a young child yes yeah
they played they derailed your life
played a big part
it wrecked my life my stepfather it was
my stepfather brought the drugs in my
house
it was my stepfather that brought it all
in my my stepfather was an
ex-cia agent he's an army intelligence
ca cia he is yes and he studies war the
guy studies war and plays war games
all the time and he [ __ ] the russians
hey foxy rises
he's with the kremlin he [ __ ] the
russians he said he's a traitor to the
flag i'm just telling you
who's got to do i'm going to burn his
[ __ ] ass when i get back to ben shaw
i'm going to burn his ass down because
he so i called i called my one squad
called
ask him for a little help people and
give me nothing turn his back on
you know he's never been any kind of
father towards me
at all he never has he's never been any
kind of father
he's he's never he's never thrown a
baseball with me he's never done
anything for me man
except for you know he's been there for
my mother he's
he's been he was married to my mother
for 45 years before she died
and that you know that's that's what i
respect about the guy because my
my my my my my real dad left when i was
seven
i left my mother when i was seven and uh
you know
my real dad was a drunk and he was a
gambler and uh you know that's why he
moved out
you know and my real dad stuck in the
san diego
uh a veteran's hospital because somebody
in l.a caved his head in
and made him brain dead and someone in
l.a did that man
and uh yeah my dad my dad's still there
i can't get them out they won't let me
get them out and i finally got it took
me four years to get state id
took me four years to get a state id i
finally got one finally got a california
state id
and i landed losing it for nothing
i don't know all right bill well thank
you so much for sharing your story
thank you i wish you the best of luck
out there man thank you thank you i got
one more
he's russian gangsters these russian
dangers oh man
there's some there's some real funny
funny weird-ass people man
they've already threatened my life twice
since i've been been
back in l.a since 15. i got back in the
alley since 2015.
and uh they've already threatened my
life for some [ __ ] reason i don't
know what's up with them but
i don't [ __ ] with russians don't do it